witches and wizards we have a big rumor
on what would be another huge
announcement for Harry Potter fans in
what has already been an incredible year
for video games in the Wizarding World
we've had the long-awaited release of
Hogwarts Legacy the global launch of
Harry Potter magic awakened which is so
underrated by the way if you haven't
played it you should give it a chance
updates to Harry Potter Hogwarts mystery
and even the announcement of a dedicated
Quidditch game in Harry Potter Quidditch
Champions so what could possibly be left
for Potter fans in 2023 while that takes
us to today's rumor I'll break it down
for you here and also give my thoughts
on whether or not I believe it's
legitimate you see there are quite a few
reports popping up online about a new
Lego Harry Potter game but not just a
small update to the previous games these
rumors State the series is set to
receive a massive update similar to
2022's Lego Star Wars the Skywalker Saga
now that game lets you play through the
story of all nine Mainline Star Wars
movies which added more open areas for
exploration as well as 45 total levels
140 side missions 731 puzzles 135 level
challenges and 380 characters this rumor
actually started back in March when
Nintendo life reported on multiple
cancellations at TT games including
projects for Lego Disney and Guardians
of the Galaxy among others while about
halfway through that article there was a
line stating that one of the games not
canceled was a quote long rumored
Skywalker Saga style treatment for the
Lego Harry Potter series close quote
fast forward to today where we have a
new report that actually originated from
an official WB account the image which I
won't be posting here due to copyright
reasons was quickly removed from the
account it featured a Lego Harry Potter
minifigure with a date of 8 25 23 as
well as the logo for TT games video
games Chronicle reached out to a person
with knowledge of the project and while
they were able to confirm the Lego Harry
Potter game is still in development they
could not confirm if the advertisement
was legitimate now that 8 25 23 date is
significant as it occurs during this
year's Gamescom which is Europe's
largest gaming event it's also just a
few days before September first which
Wizarding World fans know as back to
Hogwarts Day last year Hogwarts Legacy
had a huge presence during the back to
Hogwarts stream as they gave fans a more
detailed look at the common rooms and
also announced an account link feature
that let fans link their Wizarding World
to their WB accounts which then unlocked
special in-game items personally I'm
still holding out hope for Hogwarts
Legacy to have something to show
possibly a DLC tease but more details on
the Lego Harry Potter game would be a
pretty nice update as well Lego Harry
Potter years 1-4 was originally released
in 2010 and then years 5-7 came in 2011.
the whole collection was then bundled
together and released on the PS4 in 2016
and then again in 2018 on Xbox One and
Nintendo switch so with the hype from
Hogwarts Legacy in five years since the
last Lego Harry Potter game the timing
certainly seems perfect for a new title
all that being said I'm not sure we
should expect the game to actually
launch in 2023 I think it's far more
likely we see an official trailer at
Gamescom but personally I'd be surprised
to see the game this year consider that
Lego Star Wars the Skywalker Saga was a
fish announced in December of 2019 and
intended to ship in 2020. unfortunately
that whole 2020 thing happened and the
game saw a series of delays that ended
up pushing it all the way to 2022 on the
positive side though the game was a big
hit with both fans and critics alike
with some even saying it wasn't just a
good Lego game but one of the best Star
Wars games ever made and personally I
think the Lego games that have already
been made in the Harry Potter Universe
are among the best Potter games ever
made now we also have to consider the
cancellations of those other titles
which certainly freed up TT to focus
more on the Star Wars game and
presumably the Harry Potter game so I
have to say I do believe this leak is
legit and I expect we'll hear more at
Gamescom and right now I would bet on an
early 2024 release I guess I'm gonna
need to add to my Harry Potter game
collection here pretty soon I recently
went on a quest to buy every single game
in the series and it was quite the
adventure let me tell you you should
check that video out next I'll link it
here on the right side of your screen as
always guys thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon